there was some sentiment across the
country that the government should do
everything I mean haunted that milk at
2008 and he came in novice they were
protecting a shortfall of about 150
million dollars heading into 2012 but we
also found a lot of waste frankly if
people were missing a trash cart or did
not have a trash cart generally speaking
it would take you're gonna have a hard
time with this I know it would take
about 150 days to get that trash cart
twenty percent plus or the phone calls
were being dropped on I mean I could go
on and on about a lot of stuff it's got
a funny because I remember driving in
early two thousand eight over the roads
of Indianapolis and I just a mayor a few
months I said boy these roads are just
not good my public works department
estimated that we were at least a
billion dollars behind an infrastructure
in the city just to get it to fair or
good condition
that's what I say I said find me my toll
road and two people in Indiana I write
knows what the toll road is situation
where governor daniels was very creative
and got four million four billion
dollars in the bank rather quickly for
his what is called the major moves
program in the state of Indiana the city
owned the water company which is uh it
did not own it until 2002 it was
privately owned until 2002 when the city
bought it now without going into the
merits of that transaction I'll just say
that the city owned it bought it for
five hundred and some million dollars
when I came into office it was in debt
900 plus million dollars we put out what
we called a request for an expression of
interest and we got 24 replies the most
curious one being from citizens who
already has three utilities in this in
the city of Indianapolis or in the
region and they were looking at the
taking over the water in the wastewater
combined from us and we were able to
work out the deal with citizens energy
to put the water and the waste water in
there now when they they took on a
billion and a half a debt but the assets
are worth one point nine so we wind up
with 425 million dollars cash but in the
last two years we probably put 250
million dollars into our roads sidewalks
bridges and alleys and taking down
abandoned homes and it hadn't cost
taxpayer dime in fact as a result of
that deal not only do we and this is
very important to me it can't
overemphasize this we took politics out
of water and wastewater anybody who's
been the city government knows there's a
lot of politics and water and wastewater
there won't be any more
I could give you a list I mean it's just
amazing solid waste pickup I mean it we
saved a million dollars in just that
because we were having trucks all over
the city picking up every day well
somebody came up with the idea of pretty
simple idea really why don't we in this
quadrant of the city why don't we pick
it up on monday in this quadrant and
tuesday so that if their trucks broke
down which they always do then you have
a truck in the nearby area it doesn't
have to travel 30 miles to get there
I've got great technology now in my
parking meters I got 20 million cash and
as I tell people I don't have salary I
don't have pensions I don't have
infrastructure costs i don't have
maintenance costs i don't have insurance
costs i just take the money now we got
less than one percent of the calls being
dropped the average phone is answered in
less than 10 seconds used to be answered
in about two minutes we let people go
online to put in the request to fix
weeds or fix the pothole or whatever and
then we also just very recently went to
an app for the iphone in the ipad or
they can take a picture of the bottle or
Louise whatever and zap it over to us
immediately and in most instances we
actually called people back and say is
this fixed we took an iconic baseball
field which has been empty for 15 years
and its really when I say iconic it's
becoming more of an eyesore and they're
turning it into really in apartments in
there which are going to be dramatic
Public Safety and criminal justice that
complex combined is about eighty to
eighty-five percent of our budget we've
asked other people of the efficient but
now we're going to ask Public Safety to
be fishing we have to ask who does what
why are you doing that because there's
so many vested interests that have grown
up over the years and somebody comes up
to me says that's the way we've always
done it that's in my antenna goes up I
think people should try to partner with
people and even people who might make a
buck or tube it's all okay because of
the city benefits of the citizens
benefit I think we should go in that
direction I really do